desantis suspends state attorney for
refusing to enforce bans on child
surgeries
and abortion restrictions this this
morning um
rhonda sanchez did this announcement
where he basically said
this george soros-backed state attorney
was
outright refusing to enforce the law in
a blanket statement and he was like look
it's one thing if you use your
discretion on an individual basis like
okay this guy shouldn't be charged with
this crime for this one reason here's
why it's another thing when you come out
you sign a document saying i will never
enforce the law so ron desantis as the
executive of florida
suspended the state's attorney and then
put in a temporary replacement to
actually enforce the law this is
tremendous
george soros
recently issued a statement
he published an op-ed saying he will not
back down from this he will keep funding
district attorneys to reform the system
or i should say he will keep fighting to
reform the system of prosecution because
it's not working for our communities
it's creating distrust between the
people and the police the crazy thing is
this guy is either completely evil or
dumb as a box of rocks and considering
his wealthy he's as wealthy as he is i
don't think he's that stupid
if you look at what's happening in san
francisco chicago new york los angeles
yeah i don't think anyone's going to be
convinced this plan is working you look
at san francisco and they recalled that
guy just boudine or whatever his name is
they recalled him the new the new person
who came in says they're going to go
after all the drug dealers now so
clearly whatever it is that soros is
thinking he's funding is pissing
everybody off
ron desantis
he's draining that swamp it's one of the
one of the one of the first major moves
i've seen from any executive to go
against these corrupt
states attorneys we'll see if anyone
goes after the district attorneys if to
the extent that they can but this is
huge huge huge victory for
accountability and maybe we'll start
seeing some stuff and then on top of
that
you know i'll just add this before
throwing it to you guys donald trump
said he was going to fire everybody i
dig it ron desantis just fired a guy i
mean he didn't really suspended him but
uh i think that's fairly promising for
if ronnie sanders ends up running for
for president 2024
yeah i really agree with that i'm not i
got mixed feelings about authority
authority authoritation authorities
using their power to just fire somebody
that's not doing bending to their will
but there is a reason for that his will
though it's just the law
that he's not
he didn't put the law in place personal
people voted people voted for a
legislature who then passed bills and
had them signed then it it got a
sufficient amount of votes and then
rhonda said he's like okay yeah sign the
bill and then this guy he issued a
statement he was like i am signing a
statement saying i will never enforce
that law so hopefully if desantis has
integrity even if it's a law he
personally disagrees with he would do
the same thing
yeah yeah i think the second what i was
the second part of what i was saying is
that sometimes the authority with the
reason they have the ability to fire
somebody that's not bending to their
will is because you know we need
authority we need a strong leader at
least society's our species since the
dawn of time has like an authority the
military commander the
commander-in-chief the one that's like
you put them up against the wall
whatever they're like you're not gonna
you're not gonna support the military
cause you're a danger to our freedom and
our survivability
the power that i have the ability to do
with you what i will but the power here
that's being exercised it's limited ron
desantis doesn't decide what the law is
he does however it it is within his
duties to to make sure that if other
people within government aren't doing
their jobs if they're derelictive duty
or negligent that he removes them and
that's in the constitution
i i'm so surprised to see such a bold
move because it feels like especially
with the republican party they just sit
on their hands
now ron desantis is like he came out and
he just went at it and he was like nah
get him out of there here's boom
executive order did it say is this like
a temporary suspension
they're trying to make it permanent but
they've put someone else in in place
what do you think about it yeah i mean
it is
you know it's interesting with the left
the left is uh supportive of
local control and localism when it suits
its purposes and then it's supportive of
centralized control and authority uh
when it doesn't and
so you know here you've got somebody
who's a prosecutor who's essentially
involved in prosecutorial nullification
right essentially you've got a duly
enacted statute that's passed by the
florida legislature signed into law by
the governor and this prosecutor is
refusing to enforce the law as as you
said tim right he's uh he's not just
exercising discretion on individual
cases he's
saying he's basically giving the finger
to the people of the state of florida by
refusing to enforce the law
so you know it is it is
good to see
someone stand up and say no you are
going to do this yo you are going to uh
follow the law you are going to apply it
and
and and you know in a red state where
there are these blue enclaves right that
this is a red state and this is the way
we do things here let me read this quote
in june of 2021 he signed a letter
saying that he would not enforce any
prohibitions on sex change operations
for minors
sex changes are really disfiguring these
young kids and he said it doesn't matter
what the legislature does in the state
of florida
florida has said you cannot perform sex
change operations on children this guy
said he would not enforce a prohibition
on that i just got to say
i don't think anyone predicted because
we had rick santorum here
i don't think anyone predicted that a
slippery slope meant within 10 years you
would have children getting sex change
surgeries
now a bunch of news outlets they refer
to it as gender affirming health care
and i take issue with that because that
is not what ronda santa said
specifically ron desantis is citing
surgery operations like going to
children we
i don't think society would tolerate
breast implants that's a gender
affirming treatment right no gender
there's a psychological thing it has
once you start to carve up physical
bodies it's another it's sex that's or
it's at least non-sexual
surgery
gender is an idea it's a concept it's a
way of feeling it once you start cutting
into it man that's that's another
well that's just agree that gender is a
feeling
that's the point of how you identify
but gender identity is different from
gender so these are these are
post-modern definitions of what gender
is that's gender was used since it
started coming into prominent prominence
in the 50s to specifically mean
biological sex that's that's very
confusing because sex means sex
gender means gender so you get they're
different words with different meanings
that's very important
so that's that's that's actually a new
concept that's so funny the different
words the word gender and sex is new
yeah so that you can have the identity
be anything you want but i thought it
used to be your sex was what you your
your gonads basically and then your
gender was how you identified and it
didn't have to be
no one identified as anything they were
just
what they were yeah like the 50s
it appeared that this idea of gender was
like in the 50s or something like that
so the words the word the word gender
has been used for a long time it comes
from genre actually i was looking into
the history of the word it came into
prominence in the 50s with people like
john money and
i don't was kinsey the 50s i'm not
entirely sure sheamus knows all about
this and so i started reading a bit
about it but um
gender was used as a word
academically they were trying to say
it's like the social constructs around
it but colloquially for most of
of english-speaking humans it just
referred to your biological sex
oh kinsey was 1947 it was when you
founded the institute for research and
sex gender and uh what was the other one
yeah so most people when they say gender
reproduction on your legal form it says
gender m or f right if it says gender
and it's a reference to male or female
they're not talking about how you feel
they're asking you about your body and
you know why they do because this is
really important in the early 1990s
there was a law that was passed
when they would do medical testing they
wouldn't do it on women
and then all of a sudden people started
realizing something you know those pain
killers we use doing during surgeries
women keep complaining that it's not
working hey wait a minute hypothesis
maybe these drugs don't work on women
sure enough they found out that certain
pain killers work on men and women
differently and so then there was a law
passed saying when you're doing medical
testing you have to have female and male
trials this is why it's very important
they know what your biological sex is
now that they're changing the definition
of gender and then changing it back it's
the funny thing um
we're getting to this point where
there's a reason that we ask these
questions
if you if if someone collapses on the
street and and a medic runs up
it's it's it actually is important that
they know if you are male or female for
a variety of reasons for instance if a
man screams and says ah my my my gut oh
man it's hurting right in my pelvic area
well there's a very different reason
that that may be happening compared to
what would be happening to a woman
but it could be appendicitis and it
could be a bunch of other things and so
there are some things for obvious
reasons men and women have different
organs that
a pain in a certain area could be
something or some could be one thing or
not
obviously but my point is
there are certain medical treatments
they will give to a male not a female
and if they can't tell or they don't
know or they don't know that a person is
taking drugs for for you know gender
affirmation as they're calling it well
then you could be seriously screwed up
when a medic gives you a medication that
it's counterindicated by whatever it is
you're taking yeah you got to make sure
that people don't you there's a story of
a woman that was following google maps
or something or apple maps into the des
and it was telling her to turn left go
straight and she just kept following the
computer into the desert her car broke
it was the wrong direction so if someone
just is like
thinking gender is all that matters what
i think is all that matters they're
basically driving their car on this
automated concept if it gets to a point
where you need to to perform life-saving
medical treatment on that person and
then you do the wrong sex because
they've conflated what they feel with
gender and their sex then it's just like
it could end up being catastrophic for
someone well now the life-saving medical
treatment that they're referring to is
gender affirmation because essentially
they're holding these kids hostage
in a way
saying like they're going to commit
suicide if they don't get these
treatments do you want them to commit
suicide
yeah they're holding them hostage and
and and the i think what's what's what's
the crazy thing about it is if you look
at countries scandinavia for instance
they've stopped doing all this
they there was like a there's a big
article for another day sweden is like
they're doing mental
you know therapies and stuff right now
because perhaps the solution to someone
who's got suicidal ideation is not
affirming what is driving their ideation
isn't
scandinavia or maybe just the
netherlands where assisted suicide uh
i don't think the netherlands is
scandinavian are they i don't think it's
like
was either in scandinavia or in the
netherlands
so it's uh like like sweden had this big
move where they were like we're not
gonna do this i don't know exactly where
they're at now but i know people have
been talking about the scandinavian
countries being like
we have found that it's not actually
reducing suicidal ideation and so that
that's my thing it's like seriously we
don't want kids harming themselves has
it been found that it worsens
suicidal ideation i don't think no i i i
don't know i don't keep up with that
yeah i've read that it's um
i've read some articles saying it's like
no difference
um but obviously it depends on what you
read if you read like advocacy websites
they're gonna say of course it's helping
reduce these things and it's like oh
maybe i don't know what i do know is
what these other countries have have
written news articles from these
countries that i've read is that
the mentality is if someone is
experiencing suicidal ideation
affirming what it is that is that is
contributing to it is not necessarily an
appropriate solution so if someone is
feeling
you know let's just say dysmorphic a
general dysmorphia like anorexia or
eating too much or you know they want
amputations or whatever
they were like
giving a person who is suffering from
some kind of anxiety
that tree like what they're asking for
is probably not the appropriate way to
stop them from feeling this way it's
kind of like if if your kid is afraid
that there's a ghost under their bed and
you're like yeah there is a ghost under
your bed and then you start building
their room to protect from this fake
ghost and then the kid goes even crazier
because it starts to think really that
that but i agree that you do need to
affirm these people not in you need to
affirm their existence people need to be
heard and understood and listened to
that's what these people need more than
anything you don't need to start i mean
put the knives down for a minute and
listen to these people like jazz
jennings we were listening to a video
from her last night she just released a
book i don't necessarily agree with
what's in the world the book
so she's got had a book off but she
needs to be listened to we all need that
we and it's not like it's it's do it or
or the world blows up but to survive and
for the betterment of humanity people
need to be listened to
jazz jennings person
had parents who
seemed to impose this identity
since
you're very young age like two years old
when
they they see their their child who they
think is a boy wearing a towel
on his head and then they're like okay
you're a girl now
and jazz
put them on tv and we're just supposed
to
accept that as as normal
yeah that's our entertainment now this
is what concerns me about uh jazz in
particular is the uh
she put out a video saying that since
two two years old she's felt this work
or whatever and and i'm i have concerns
first memory is even that early
yeah that's insane you know like i have
can you guys remember when you were i
remember peeing on my brother one time i
think i was like four and he was like
yeah he was two i was like being two
years old i don't know i don't know so
so look certainly i'm not as complex as
that i do have questions though like if
if we're gonna talk about florida and
the parental rights and education stuff
and the rights of the parents to choose
what's for what's right for their kids
then you have to define what your moral
line is because if we're then going to
question the parents of jazz jennings
it's like
do we then intervene in their family as
a governmental body do we say the
government must intervene or stop that
if we think it's wrong or do we then say
we don't want the government intervening
in what parents think is right for their
kids
and there's questions of
if if a kid really is
you know suicidal and i'm not talking
about two years old
and
doctor prescribes something
do we as the layman then say we've
decided to intervene i mean
let's let's keep our more our our our
morality logical right in the same path
so i'm on high alert against medical
tyranny and for-profit surgeries on kids
is devastating it's really bothering me
but i i think people also should have
the freedom to do what they want with
their bodies now we talk about a kid
kids don't have the ability to consent
to things the parents basically
consenting for them and so is it ethical
for a for a 45 year old parent to have a
13 year old kid cut i don't know i don't
yeah what
that have adopted that identity before
they're adults and then once they're
adults
they
continue to
to keep that identity and seek medical
procedures because of it
i don't think that that person has
informed consent of what of the
procedures that they're seeking well i
don't i don't think children can consent
so right but once they're adults and
they've they've already been groomed to
believe that this is who they are
they don't have the ability to make an
informed
consensual decision about the about the
medical treatment i don't agree with
that at all yeah i can't make that
decision for others
that negates everyone's life
you know look i i don't think children
should be getting sex change surgery i
think that's like where we're we're
going on a dangerous path but to say
that
you know you're 16 and you had an
experience that informed you of
something and you chose to follow that
so you can't be adequately informed
because of that okay jazz jennings since
two years old
the parents have been in charge of that
right from what happens
and then jazz jennings
18 and up that now has the ability to
consent to further
medical interventions well i think after
being groomed so thoroughly into
believing that
that is their identity i see what you're
saying
but the challenge doesn't follow
there's there's this is such a
there's like a hard line for obviously
like don't give sex changes to kids that
i can't believe is actually a political
debate that's happening right now and
to what extent does the government
intervene when someone prescribes a
medical treatment to a child you don't
agree with
so i'm i'm at a loss to to to be to be
honest like i i think it's great what uh
rhonda sanders did i think that if
you've got a law that's been you know
from
duly elected
and a bill has been sworn this is the
question this is the question for social
media what is what is what is youtube's
position on the fact that in florida it
is a crime
to perform a sex change on a child
how do we are
our youtubers advocating for illegal
activity now no you you what's what are
the rules
so i i'm saying
for me
i look at what's going on in florida
we have consistently said over the past
year parents should have the final say
in what their kids are you know and how
to raise their kids
and then you get people coming out and
saying okay well my doctor said my kid
should undergo this treatment and it's
like no i think you should uh wait a
minute i just said parents should have
final say yeah but
it does obvious lines though like if a
parent was abusing the child and then we
have to decide what those moral lines
are simply put florida has decided no
sex change surgery for kids yeah i mean
and in north carolina i can tell you uh
we had an interesting proposal made by
the
duke law school around homeschooling and
my wife and i homeschooled our kids
and there was a proposal that was put
forth to amend north carolina's
child abuse laws to define something
called educational neglect
so what's educational neglect under this
proposal well when you start to boil it
down it really means
if you're not providing an education
that a judge
deems to be adequate so
ultimately you know judges make make the
call
but it becomes you know sort of
inherently politicized so am i am i
giving my child an adequate education if
i'm teaching them that there are only
two you know male and female um am i
giving my child an adequate education if
i'm teaching them um you know
uh real american history right like um
so
you know what to your point students
subject to standardized testing
it depends on the state in north
carolina you have to test i think it's
every two years
that's messed up i'm totally opposed to
to uh to run a run a home school
but you know do you draw lines to say
for what parents can do right in terms
of okay there's a difference between how
you're going to educate your kids right
and your control over the education your
kids versus
making these kinds of decisions about
your child's future and the ability of
society to second guess those decisions
this is this we have a cultural problem
it always comes down to this and i i i
want people to understand
if a parent says i'm going to show my
kids graphic images it's like okay well
now you've got questions like
is the violation of the law does the law
define showing lewd images to children
does you can't do that however the
problem is these parents are going to
doctors and the doctors saying this is
what you have to do
not only that but often when the parents
defy the doctors the state comes in in
certain states and punishes the parents
so now you've got this this is a this is
i'm telling you man
when i talk about the bifurcation of
this country
in florida for instance
sex change on on children not allowed
in in other states i mean even in texas
we saw that case where the mom wanted to
transition the son the the little boy
and the dad didn't and there was like
the judge ruled in favor of the mom
so
you've got these stories about parents
who are like
a doctor said it
so they agreed and then what we're
supposed to say is like well you know
far be it for me to say what's what's
you know what's in the what what what
the child should get if a doctor is
saying it but then you have parents who
can't even decide in some areas when the
doctor says it they say no now they get
in trouble the inverse is florida
it's illegal to do like we're we are
we're getting to the point where you're
going to have two states next to each
other one's going to florida completely
illegal then you're going to have
another state being like totally legal
and then what the mother's going to
kidnap the kid to bring them somewhere
to get this gender affirming health care
or what what uh florida refers to as
prohibited child sex changes even the
language on what's happening is totally
different
it's kind of the way it's supposed to be
that every states gets to pick its own
way of being and then we have a federal
government to make sure that you don't
that there are some things that are just
off off the ret off the books you can't
drive 180 miles an hour anywhere in the
country you can't kill people legally
you can drive well you can kill my mind
more permissible than child sex changes
yeah but ian you are incorrect there are
places in this country where you can
drive i was being hyperbolic and off the
off the hip that was stupid of me uh on
private property you can go as fast as
you want and they actually have
permitted areas where they do high-speed
testing so well but the point is
you did a good job
there are things that the federal
government will say yo state you can't
say that's okay murder's not okay you
can't say that in your state you know
you can't abuse your citizens basically
i don't know i don't i don't know about
that is that true well i mean that's it
it really
you know it's an interesting question in
light of the dobbs decision right
because there are people on
you know the issue of abortion
uh who believe and there were briefs
that were submitted in that case
uh where uh people took the position
that abortion is unconstitutional
just flatly that that unborn children
are persons under the 14th amendment and
that
all states have to treat those persons
equally and so
if uh a state a state would have to uh
ban the murder of an unborn unborn child
so abortion is flatly prohibited
nationally i honestly under that
analysis versus sort of the more you
know classic
conservative legal
approach to the question which is i
think what the court ultimately uh
adopted and dobbs which is that the
constitution is just silent on this
question and it's an issue for each
individual state thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there